A former dancer, Mary studied
structural integration with Ida Rolf.
She has taught movement in bodywork
classes since 1994 and was chair of the
Movement Faculty of the Rolf Institute
of structural integration in Boulder,
Colorado. The new rules of posture
is the second of three books.
Mary has published along with numerous
articles in magazines including massage
shape,
men's fitness,
somatics journey journal and massage
and bodywork. Her newest book,
your Bali Body Mount.
Our posture as a path to presence is
coming out at the end of the year.
You can look at it, look for it
on her website or on Amazon. Uh,
she has videos, a blog, and much
more on her website, which is www.
Heal your posture.com. Ladies
and gentlemen, Merry Bond.
Thank you all so much for coming.
I know we had an eclipse and there were
other exciting things going on today and
here you are.
So sitting,
standing and moving in the modern
world is not always comfortable,
but we get used to it.
A lot of times we don't
notice our discomfort until
it becomes full blown pain.
So you folks are Google,
you're known for innovation.
And what I hope to do today is to inspire
you to help redesign the way the world
works so it could be more body friendly.
So,
um,
because I want you to feel what
I'm talking about in your bodies.
I'm going to ask you to stand
up and do things every so often.
So now is one of those times, if you
would just stand up, it would be great.
Okay? So bring your arms way high,
make fists, tighten your elbows,
tighten your knees,
push down in the floor,
stretch your spine as high as possible.
And then go side to side. Just a little.
So notice your stretching,
but you're contracting at the same time.
That's important. Really
stretch, really reach. Okay,
now open your hand.
Scrunch up your eyes.
Open your mouth like you're yawning.
A more stretch, more and more.
Okay.
Now you could let go
and feel your body right now.
Something a little something, a
little energy moving through it. Yeah.
So what you just did is Pandic.
Culation and most mammals
do this many times a day,
sometimes up to 50 times.
But humans feel a little
sheepish doing it in public.
Nonetheless, you felt there was an
effect, I think nod your head. Yeah,
there was an effect.
So what might be news is that that
affect matters. It's important.
So we'll talk a little more about
Penn [inaudible] as we go forward.
This is cover art for the
book you just picked up.
And the gist of that book is
that posture isn't a position.
It's not what you do with your shoulders
or your head or your gut posture is
your response to this moment and
the next moment and the next,
every succeeding moment
requires you to respond.
We don't, we're not aware of it
and we get habits about doing it.
But basically posture is how you feel
stable and safe in a pretty unstable
world.
And so changing,
transforming your posture amounts to
creating different strategies for how you
feel safe inside to meet the world.
So it's in involves body awareness,
self awareness. It's not a quick fix.
So this book is not something
you're going to, um,
benefit from tomorrow.
It takes a little patience.
So how do we sit,
stand and move in this crazy modern world
in a world that increasingly ignores
what the body is made to do,
which is to move.
Um,
all organisms move in order to survive.
We know that there's a doctor
Scholls ad on television right now.
It says,
born to move.
So we have this in our consciousness
and yet we don't really embody it in our
being.
So how many of you have standing desks?
Yeah.
Do you stand at them? They
will. That help? It's helpful.
Sometimes you do sometimes.
Yeah.
So standing desks and Ergonomic
chairs are good ideas. Um,
but they're external fixes to the problem
of our ancient bodies in this modern
world.
So I want to dig a little deeper
into the nature of your bodies.
I want to talk about what you're made
of the ground substance of your body and
how to take care of that.
I want to talk about the architectural
principle that holds you together and
about perception and what
perception has to do with posture.
And then I'll give you some advice about
sitting since you're insist on doing
that. And we'll talk about in the end, uh,
exercise and movement and
the future of the human body.
So that's my plan for this little talk.
And I wanted to share with you a
little about where I'm coming from.
This is my teacher,
her name was Ida Rolf
and she was a biochemist,
but her passionate interest
was in human structures.
So she developed a manual therapy.
She called structural integration.
And so her students and her
clients nicknamed it Raul thing.
She didn't much like that.
But now most of you have
heard of Raul thing. Yes.
Okay.
So this therapy looks at the
body as living architecture,
which has been distorted and diminished
by accidents and compensations and poor
use,
like sitting all day without moving.
She viewed pain as the product,
mostly the product of imbalance structure.
She had to kind of revolutionary ideas
for the sixties this expresses one of
them. It's her logo. And
she thought that the body,
she taught that the body
is organized by gravity,
just like this building
is organized by gravity.
So if the body could be balanced,
then gravity wouldn't tear the body down,
but would in fact actually
contribute to health.
So that was her first idea.
Or second idea is that the body's
connective tissue is plastic.
It's able to change.
So through manipulation,
she found that she could restore balance
to structures that had become distorted
and twisted.
She was the first to recognize the
importance of connective tissue,
what we now call Fascia.
And she died in 1979.
Uh, but the first research
conference about Fascia,
the Fascia congress wasn't
held until 2006. Uh,
it happened at Harvard,
which was exciting for us body workers.
But it was also attended by many
researchers from around the world who had
become interested in this aspect of
the body that had mostly been ignored.
So this is a simple
metaphor to share with you.
How fascia pervades your body.
The rind of the orange is like,
um,
an all over body suit just under your
skin. If we peeled off all the skin,
we would see a fascicle layer.
It's, it's literally a body suit.
It contains everything else.
And underneath that are these,
the segments of the orange, um,
represent the various organs and muscles
and larger structures that each have a
containing membrane as, as, um,
blood vessels and nerves and bones all
have a wrapping of Fascia around them.
And all of this Fascia is continuous
and the little orange bits inside the
segments, you know how your fingers
get sticky when you eat an orange.
So those little bits represent cells.
So each cell in your body has
its own fashional membrane.
So it's been suggested that if you took
out everything else from the body except
the Fascia, you'd still have
a recognizable human shape.
This is an 18th century
painting of a dissection.
It hangs in the Wellcome
library in London.
So until recently,
anatomists stripped away the Fascia and
discarded it so they could look at the
interesting thing.
So the liver and the brain and
the circulatory system and so on.
And that was good.
We needed that.
But what it did was perpetuate the
idea that your body is made up of an
assemblage of parts.
Rather than that it becomes,
develops out of wholeness,
which I'll talk about a little more later.
Yeah.
This photo is an endoscopic
image of living Fascia.
It's magnified 130 times and it's
the work of a man named John Claude.
Gene Bartow.
He's a French micro surgeon.
He uses endoscopy in his work.
So this means putting little cameras
and lights and micros scopes inside the
living tissue.
So he has been so odd by what he saw
that he's developed a collection of these
images.
And I can give you his
website after the talk.
Appreciate these geometric forms.
Uh, immune system. Uh, sorry.
The fascist system is now being studied
at the same way that the immune system
and the circulatory system and all
the other systems are being studied.
So there are three main
constituents of Fascia.
One is Collagen.
It's like protein fibers,
which when they're woven tightly
together have the strength of steel.
There are also elastic fibers that you
could stretch to 100% of their capacity
and then they could relax back
without deforming their shape.
And the third constituent is a watery
matrix, something like egg white,
uh,
kind of mucousy stuff.
And there's swimming in cells like immune
cells and fat cells and nerve cells.
So this was very interesting to us in
the bodywork world that there were nerve
cells in Fascia.
We we knew from doing doctor Rovs work
that there was some kind of communication
through the Fascia, but we had all
kinds of other ideas about what, what,
what was doing it.
And they're actually sensory nerve
fibers in the fashion. In fact,
six times estimated six
times as many nerve fascists,
neuro fibers in Fascia as in muscle.
So when you think you're
moving through the,
your neuromuscular system,
it's actually the fashion system that
is allowing that to come into full
expression.
Yeah.
A lot of these nerves,
sensors in the fascia
are called intro sectors.
That means they tell you what's
going on inside your body.
So when you feel bloated or you have
a tickle or an itch or you have sexual
arousal or air hunger,
all of these kinds of sensations in your
body are because of the intro sectors
in your Fascia. So you
might think that, uh,
interoception is a way,
you know that you have a body.
Okay.
Lot of different textures.
Fascia can assume it can have
the transparency of glass.
So your corneas are Fascia,
your breasts are Fascia
full of lots of fat cells.
Um, there's um, when you,
when you have a scar that's the Collagen
fibers woven tightly together to
protect the wound.
Um,
it's also very fluid gelatin
like slidey slippery slidey.
So when we watch our most
beautiful athletes and dancers,
what we're seeing is not just
their superb neuromuscular system,
but also the health of their fashion
system. Note, the last point,
stress and immobility dehydrates your
Fascia and makes it stiff and makes you
stiff.
So stress in a mobility are the
characteristics of the modern workplace.
The powerful leaping of a kangaroo is
do not just to its powerful leg muscles,
but to the high percentage
of Fascia in its body.
So when those elastic fibers
stretch through movement,
uh, the, its stores, kinetic energy,
which is then released
and the kangaroo rebounds.
Interesting thing here is that our bodies,
human bodies have the same high percentage
of fashion in them as the kangaroo.
So if you think about that,
it's clear that we're made for leaping
and running and not for sitting.
This is a video,
one of gene bertos videos of
living Fascia. You'll see,
um,
the yellow fat cells along the bottom,
tendonous material,
the collagen across the middle of the
slide and the blood cell blood vessel.
You might be able to see moving.
So where that's happening is just
below your elbow on your forearms.
So find that place on yourself.
I'm going to play the video again,
but um, if you make just a pinch
of skin with your finger pads,
just a gentle pinch of
skin and pull up on it.
And when the video starts,
you could slowly let down on the pinch
and then draw up again as the video goes
up.
Now it's coming down,
you're letting go of your pinch,
and then you're pulling up.
Images are so amazing.
Yeah.
So that kind of shape shifting is going
on inside your body with every movement
that you make while you're breathing.
While you're brushing your teeth
while you're rolling over in bed.
Okay,
this is another one of gene Bertos,
um,
videos and it takes place in the same
place, but it's a little different.
It's magnified 10 times.
The other one was magnified 20 times.
And this one is also a
deeper place in the forearm.
So take the palm of one hand and press
it lightly against the skin just below
your elbow as if those two layers of
skin where move or adhered to each other.
And then what you do is just a gentle
pulling down of this skin toward your
wrist. And you might be able to feel
that you're not just pulling on skin,
but other layers are moving underneath
and then draw up toward your elbow with
that same thing.
So that's what's going on here.
The bubbles that you see are because
of the difference in pressure between
what's going on,
the incision and the air outside
pressure differential.
Notice that changing direction
of these microfibers,
how they keep reorienting themselves,
changing their polarities.
It's like a crystal and
kaleidoscope inside you.
So you keep your fascia healthy by moving.
And the important thing is
movement in many directions.
So multidirectional movement,
not forward movement that's repetitive.
So if you had the choice between going
to a dance jam or working out on an
exercycle for the benefit of your Fascia,
you need to go dancing
probably for other reasons to
whole body stretches are
good for the fascist.
So that Pandic culation
that we did before,
as long as it's a whole body
stretch and not just, you know,
this kind of stretch of
isolated muscles that people do,
that's a different thing.
Gentle bouncing movements.
So if you went folk dancing,
that would be good for your Fascia.
Not Big leaps,
but just gentle bouncing
a micro movements.
We'll be doing some micro
movements in a few minutes.
These are small movements that
you can barely, barely see.
Certainly you can feel
the massage can help. Uh,
all of these suggestions don't cover
strength training or aerobic training.
You need that too. Of course,
this is fascist specific.
This image of an Mbr embryo is a
development about four to five weeks.
But fascia emerges in
embryonic development earlier
than this and about two
weeks. So fascia. Researchers
suggest that muscles,
bones, organs, in fact,
all other living tissue may in fact be
specializations within the unified medium
of Fascia.
So that's a very different way
of thinking about how we evolve.
Then the idea that we're just a
bunch of parts stuck together.
Everything in the fashion system is
interconnected and fluid and you can feel
this when you breathe.
So let's try.
So if you would just be comfortable
and if you feel like closing your eyes,
sometimes that helps you
feel your body more readily.
It's just go inside and feel the sort of
swelling and settling of your chest as
you inhale and exhale,
just a little expansion
and then diminishment
and you could feel it
probably also in your belly,
a little puffing up and letting go
and then turn your attention to your
shoulder blades and see if you can feel
them sliding maybe apart from each other,
maybe up a little bit.
As you inhale and resting down,
shoulder blades move apart
so the rib cage can expand
and then drop your awareness
down into your forearms.
There are two bones in your forearms
and he in each forearm and there's a
membrane in between.
So imagine that membrane swelling and
settling as you breathe in and out,
and then
come down into your lower legs.
See if you can go that far down and feel
your fascia moving as you breathe in
between the lower leg bones.
It's interesting that
the place where you feel a sensation in
your brain is the same place that you
imagine a sensation.
It's a sensory cortex,
so it doesn't matter if you think you're
only imagining it, it's good enough.
Drop down into your souls.
See if you can feel that when you inhale,
there's the slightest
pressure down into your shoes.
Yeah,
and let yourself imagine that
tensile matrix that we saw earlier.
Imagine it throughout your whole body,
all those little fibers
changing their orientation.
Thank you. You can open your
eyes. Could you feel a bit?
Imagine you felt,
but it will be a while before our culture
learns to see the body as continuous
and connected.
We think of the body and bits and pieces.
When we have a pain, we blame
it. On an isolated part.
We exercise isolated separate muscles.
We do lat pulls,
an Ab crunches.
Okay.
And when we want to
portray images of power,
we just add more and stiffer parts.
Okay?
This model suggests a way of conceiving
how the body is held together.
So it is you seeing struts held
in place by a network of tension.
Okay?
In terms of the body,
the elastic lines are your soft
tissues and the struts are your bones.
Ideally, your bones are floating
in a network of soft tissue.
This architectural principle is
called tensional tensional integrity,
or as Buckminster Fuller
called it 10 Segretti.
And you can see that if you change the
tension in just one of those strings,
the whole structure
would change its shape,
change its orientation a little bit,
and that's true inside us.
That's how we work too.
Even the vertebrae,
the Individual Vertebra in your spine
can float and respond inside this network
of tension,
but we don't think of it that way.
We talk about the spine as a column.
On the right,
you see a 10 Segretti tower.
It's a sculpture by a man
named Kenneth Snelson.
It's in the Washington
National Mall in Washington,
and you can see that it's more
similar in quality to the spine.
Then the Washington monument is,
okay,
so how do we learn to behave more like
bio 10 secretaries and less like stacks
of bricks?
Well,
it's helpful to think or imagine back
to prehistoric times how the body might
have functioned in those days.
So our prehistoric ancestors had to
move their bodies in order to survive.
So you could imagine what kind of
movements they might've had to do to kill
their breakfast or heard their cattle.
So they'd be crouching or
throwing or digging or lifting,
carrying stuff. And none of that
would be predictable or repetitive,
constantly changing movement,
large body movements.
Also,
they would be traveling
in bare feet or skins,
uh,
on uneven terrain,
which had a pebbles and foreigns in it.
So their,
their feet had to be extremely
mobile to navigate the ground
and that mobility and the feet would
play up through the whole fascist system.
So every joint in the body would have
to respond to the movements of the feet.
So that's an example of micro movement.
In a sense,
and these movements, large and
small, must have kept their fashion.
I healthy,
I like to think that anyway.
And they had to have a panoramic
view of their surroundings.
They had to have 360 degree awareness
through their all their senses,
through hearing sight.
All the factory 10th,
uh,
sent felt feeling sense
and it's as if they had eyes
in the backs of their heads.
But with us, we're always
looking forward just this way,
this way forward. So let's
practice something. Uh,
I want to see if you can feel the
benefit of having a more broad peripheral
awareness.
So you need to stand up again so you
could [inaudible] it's a good idea.
There's certain noises
that go with [inaudible].
Yeah,
it could be louder.
Okay. So find a detail somewhere
around you. Not a person,
but something you could look at.
Could be the screen or it could
be exit sign or a Thermostat,
some detail that you could gaze that with.
A lot of intensity of vision that you
have to write a report about this thing
and it's due tomorrow and your job
depends on it. So really look, look hard.
Keep that. Keep that intensity.
And notice your breathing.
Notice where it's located in your body.
Notice the relationship between your
torso and your neck and jaw and head.
Notice the sensation in your eyes.
Notice where your weight is on your feet
and how big you feel in
general. Okay, so relax that.
Just shake it out.
Yeah,
just we want to neutralize ourselves
so we can do something else.
Thank you.
So now put your fingers out like this.
Wiggle your fingers and you can see
peripherally without still looking at me.
You can still see what's
beyond your fingers.
You could put your hands down
now and just keep looking
so that you have a sense of
the periphery of the room.
And you also notice something about
what's above your head. You can feel it.
And because you walked in here,
you know what's behind you.
You have a kinesthetic
memory of what's behind you.
So you have a broad perceptual awareness.
Yeah.
So I want you to see if you can keep
that and then turn and look at your same
object that you looked at before.
And I'd like to suggest some things
that may or may not be different.
There are different when I
teach this to different people.
So I think it's possible that your
breathing lower in your rib cage,
not so high in your upper chest.
Uh,
I think your eyes feel softer
and that you feel less
merged with that object.
There's more of a sense of you
being here and it being over there.
Also, it's possible that you
see the object in its context.
So your report is going
to be more interesting.
Okay.
So great.
Thank you very much.
I like to think of this as
10 Segretti of perception.
So what I mean by that is by having these
little feelers out in all directions,
you establish a virtual
network in the space,
a virtual network of potential directions
of movement through the space that
actually helps support your body.
And I think you felt that you had
better posture the second time. Yes,
you will. You are bigger. Yeah.
And so this awareness of our surroundings
helps our bodies open up on the inside
as well as on the outside.
So we have better posture.
We actually have more strength,
which if you stay for the little
class afterwards, I can show you that.
So picture the movements
you make to get to work,
to get up, get your breakfast, go to work,
and the movements that you
make while you're at work.
I might be different at Google
than it is other places,
but generally in offices
your movements are curtailed.
You don't have a lot of movement.
Most of it is in the forward plane
and your perceptions are narrowed.
So I think it's important for us
humans to acknowledge that the amazing
conveniences that were living with in
this time may be diminishing our body's
natural capacity for
movement and perception.
So we want to change that.
I think
what can we do about sitting and
standing and moving in the workplace now?
So an expensive ergonomic chair is not
the answer because it's doesn't guarantee
that you're going to sit in a,
in a balanced way. This chair,
like many has a dip towards
the back of the seat.
So that dip tends to roll the pelvis back
and invite your spine to lean against
the backrest.
Most modern chairs are like this.
You slide back,
car seats are the worst.
Those buckets,
seats are designed to prevent movement.
Um,
if human spines don't need back
support when we're standing up,
why would we need them when we're seated?
While we don't,
as long as the pelvis is sitting
at the right inclination.
So that inclination
involves having a 45 degree,
a greater than 45 degree angle
between the hip and the thigh.
Yeah.
So this is Charles and you can see that
he's sitting more upright and on the
left and his weight,
some of his weight is being born
through his feet and his legs,
about maybe 40% of his weight
is born through legs and feet.
And so he has a broader base of support
and when his thighs are slanting down
hill that way,
and that forward inclination of the pelvis
creates an automatic lift through the
spine.
In the other picture where he's in
sitting in a lower chair that invites his
pelvis to roll back.
Like I was describing,
modern chairs are inviting you
to do in these chairs right here.
And so he's sitting on his
tailbone, on his buttocks, flesh.
His whole torso is compressed.
He looks Duller, his head
is poking forward, you know?
So let's practice this.
So unfortunately these chairs don't
raise and lower, but we can make,
do I think you can feel something if you
don't mind sitting more forward on them.
So imagine that's a bench or a stool,
not a chair with a back.
Yeah, already. That's better.
See, you can do it. All right.
So on purpose,
I'd like you to roll back this role,
this of your anatomy back like Charles
is doing in the right hand picture.
And notice what happened
to your spine and torso.
You compress these stay there.
I want you to really feel it.
So you're sitting on your buttocks
flash, right? Maybe on your tailbone.
Take a nice full easy breath.
Yeah. So it's like really not
easy to do that, you know?
But we get used to this.
We drank a lot of coffee because we're
not getting enough oxygen. All right,
stay there one more time.
One more thing.
I'd like you to notice how
creative you feel in that position.
And then just from there,
roll your pelvis forward.
So you can think of it different ways
you can think of having your pubic bone
farther from your belly button.
You can think of having, uh,
your tail moving more in back behind you.
And you're sitting now on the flesh of
your thighs rather than the flesh of your
buttocks.
So it make sense and you feel there's
more weight on your feet so you have more
support.
Yeah.
So I'd like to take this
a little bit farther.
If you don't mind reaching underneath
yourself. Find your left sit bone.
It's just in front of the gluteal
flesh. And you're right. Sit Bone.
Yeah.
And while you're back there,
find your coxix.
Just touch it so you really,
really know where it is. Okay.
So now stay seated on your thighs
and look down inside yourself.
You'll see that those three
points make a triangle.
So that makes sense. You feel that? Nod
your head. It's, these lights are glaring.
I can't see.
All right,
so that triangle is called the post
steer or triangle of your pelvic floor or
the anal triangle of the
pelvic floor. And notice. Now,
if you roll back and sit
more towards the buttocks,
that that anal triangle got smaller,
more compressed.
So that area is at the bottom of your
gut tube that connects all the way up to
your throat.
So how well can you can digest your
lunch when you're in that compressed
position?
Let's,
uh,
roll forward now once more.
And going to take this
still a little bit farther.
This is a female pelvic floor,
but the anatomy of the muscular
apparatus is pretty much the same for all
genders.
And you notice that triangle I outlined,
the anal triangle.
And notice at the bottom,
the Anal Cox, a GL ligament.
That's a little tiny slip
of Fascia between your anal
sphincter and your coxix.
So we're going to experiment
with a micro movement of that.
So you need to be sitting
comfortably upright on your thighs,
not leaning back on this backrest and
see if you can draw your coxix just a few
millimeters closer to your anal sphincter
without disturbing anything else.
That's good. You're
doing it. All right. So,
okay,
let's undo it.
So go back the other way.
See if you can just imagine that
ligament lengthening your coxix link
lengthening back.
Okay,
so I wish you could see
yourselves because there's this,
you're all sitting with nice posture,
but there's this diminishing.
Maybe you could feel it inside
yourself deep inside your anybody.
Let's do it again. You
might, you might feel it.
So be open and big and on your thighs,
on your feet.
Just move the coccsyx forward
towards the anal sphincter
and there's just a slight
shriveling up inside.
And then reverse it and go the other way.
Yeah,
so
there's a difference in the and what
happens inside your body when there's
tension around this area.
Most of us have fallen on our coxix or
had some kind of injury to the pelvic
floor sometime in our life and yet we
don't speak of it except jokes on late
night TV. You know, it's
important to think about it.
The intro sectors in your Fascia help
you feel that subtle change in your
posture that happens
because of your tail space.
So I can't resist talking about this.
It's in the news, right? This thing
I've been teaching
sitting for a long time,
and I've wondered why it is that it's
harder for men to comfortably be seated
upright in the pelvis,
harder for men and women.
So I've been asking around and what people
have told me is that there can be an
uncomfortable friction between
the skin of the scrotum,
the underwear,
and the genes.
So all of that kind of rubs
together like layers of Fascia.
So in order to sit upright,
it would require a manual adjustment
you're not going to make in public, right?
So I've also,
men have also told me that underwear
that supports the genital sooner,
more forward position makes it
easier to sit upright in the pelvis.
So I'm not gonna tell you what kind of
underwear to wear it guys, I'm really not.
But I will tell you that the orientation
of your pelvis makes a huge difference
to the decompression of your
spine and to your posture
going forward.
So take a look at old men
walking down the street and
notice they have no tail space.
I promise you they don't.
Okay.
So here,
if you can see there's a blue cushion
that Melanie is about to sit down on.
It's a desk about this big
and you blow it up with air,
but not very much so it's not bouncy.
It's more like sitting on a water bed.
So when she sits on it,
there can be a subtle reverberation.
You might see a subtle reverberation
of her spine as her pelvis just sort of
floats on that cushion.
So that's actually helping to pump
fluids into those micro fibers.
It's qualifies as a micro movement and
micro movements are good for your Fascia.
There are new articles every day about
the kind of exercise that you can do to
maintain your heart health, your
brain health, your longevity.
I'm talking about your fashion health
and sitting as particularly detrimental
for Fascia.
The hip joint is a ball and socket joint
like this and that's great for movement
is terrible for stability.
So when you sit with your legs at
that angle for long, long hours,
without much movement,
the Fascia around your hip and down
through your legs and thighs gets tighter
and matted and, and you
know, more uncomfortable.
So
it would be great if
when you take a break,
no, it's recommended that, uh,
people who sit go five
minutes every hour moving.
Do you have you,
have you heard that every hour you're
supposed to get up and move for five
minutes?
I think it's probably hard to do,
but if you did it,
it would be better to do this right,
to do this,
than to just walk around because
it's nondirectional movement.
It's innovative movement.
So think about what if people
did this around Google.
It would be just like taking
a coffee break, you know,
it's not shameful to move your body.
It's not embarrassing to
do what your body needs.
You just simply have to recognize
that your body needs it.
And I think you need to take perception
breaks because looking at I'm focused
object for a long time induces us sort
of a hypnotic trance and you know that
you work. And Work and you think, well,
just one more thing and then I'll get up,
right?
Just have to keep going.
So you need to purposefully
break the trance every so often.
One way is to put attention
into the soles of your feet.
So you could do that right now.
Just drop your attention down there.
Feel the skin of your
feet inside your shoes.
You could even feel your feet
breathing like you did before.
You could feel the little
cleavages in between your toes.
Feel your toenails,
but you're still listening to me,
right? But you're also present
in the lower part of your body.
I think what happens with
computers and technology so,
so often is that the energy of the
being gets drawn up into this part,
upper body.
I also recommend using urgency as a
trigger to widen your perceptual field.
So you know how you develop that
broad perceptual field earlier.
Okay? So let's, let's try something. If
you just take out your phone right now,
just reach it down and get your phone.
Okay? So notice your state the minute
you have the phone in your hand.
All right? Can you feel what I'm
talking about? It's like you go there,
it's like you disappear into the phone.
So the phone could be a queue.
A device could be a queue.
So keep the phone in your hand,
but take a moment to widen
your perceptual field.
So however you do that,
especially think of the space
behind your body that really helps
and keep that space and then
check Twitter. You can do it.
Okay.
It might slow you down a nanosecond.
I don't think that's bad,
but it's a way of being present with your
device rather than present inside your
device.
So when you're not at work, or maybe
even when you are, because you're here,
you could sit on the floor and the
benefit of that is it opens up those hip
joints that have been compressed and
restricted by sitting on too many chairs.
You could have lunch sitting on the floor,
you could watch a movie,
and unless you override the impulse,
you Pandic you late every
morning when you wake up,
it primes your body and primes
your Fascia for the day ahead.
So it's good.
Don't override it.
If we're going to persist
doing sedentary work,
we need to become less self
conscious about our need to move.
So here,
see if you can see the way the movement
translates through her legs and hips up
into her spine.
All of them,
the burdens on their heads
help decompress the spine.
So spinal movement is more accessible,
but notice the harmony in
the rhythm of these people.
And there's us.
I think we need to create a culture,
environments and designs that are kinder
to the human body than the hard flat
surfaces and square rooms that
we've boxed ourselves into.
Google is known for innovation.
So I'd like to leave you with a challenge.
I hope you can use your design thinking,
your engineering to help redesign the
way the world works so that people might
have to move more in to do their work.
I don't know how this could happen,
but I think you do.
And if you move more,
two things will happen.
It generates creative ideas
and it improves your posture.
So the last screen is
just, uh, some websites.
For more information you can
learn about fashion fitness.
I just briefly glossed over it.
The man's name, Robert Slide,
this one of,
he's a Rolfer in Germany.
He's also one of the
foremost Fascia researchers.
So he's developed a program.
Then there's junk call gene Bartos,
a website in case you're
interested in those images.
The International Association
of structural integrators
lists about 17 different
schools,
which teach the legacy of Ida Rolf.
She could learn more about that and my
website will tell you when my new book is
happening and I have a
newsletter but it,
I don't send it out very often so you
don't get inundated by stuff by me.
So thank you so much.
Thank you.
Oh, there's a question. That's great.
So you know when you said sit forward,
you know I did that and
I feel good and it's up,
but I get tired and then when I leaned
back I feel like I'm resting again.
So how do I not feel like I'm using
all my muscles or something to sit?
Right? Well, you all,
you will be using muscles that you
don't use because you're leaning back
habitually and you know, I don't know
how long you've been leaning back
many decades, but a decade
or two, right? Yeah.
And so you need to work
through that little by little,
I think of titration,
you know,
when you just go drop by drop to make a
change rather than expecting yourself to
sit upright all the time. But
it really will help. Help,
help to open up that tail
space and to get a broad uh,
support.
I should just practice a little
bit to do it a little. Yeah,
bet.
And sit back.
Maybe you could associate sitting upright
with certain tasks and leaning back
with other kinds of tasks.
Okay. And then try and buy us
myself more towards sitting up
of course. Okay. And exercise. Go dancing.
All right.
Can I have a prescription for that?
Yeah, I'm glad you felt it. You know,
and it does take a little bit of,
of a sincere desire to make that change.
And also in movie theaters you have to
just lean back because otherwise no one
can see around you. Yeah. There's one,
one trend behind,
I still use the ball.
It's just curious what you think
about that. Sitting on a ball.
Yeah.
Well that cushion I showed you that
cushion that's available, you know,
you search for it,
you'll find it.
So that was my solution because the
problem with the sitting on a ball is it
makes you sit like this.
Right? So I think it's,
it's better for the hip joints not
to be stuck in that wide position.
And also the ball tends to
roll back a little too much.
So I really like that Christian idea
cause it's almost like sitting on a ball.
What's the, yeah. Uh,
it's called disc. Oh sit.
And it's on Amazon disco said.
Yeah,
it's a disk on which you sit.
You are talking about having peripheral
vision and as a glasses where I wonder
if you have any thoughts or insights on
contacts versus glasses being like I've
definitely find my awareness is much
more like when this is all blurry.
Um, so I wonder if you had feelings
on that. For sure. I wear glasses too,
but I noticed that and this thing that I
taught you is one of the most important
things I ever teach anybody is
this awareness of the space,
especially the space behind you.
There's something magical about
that that makes you feel supported.
And it has, uh, I don't think it
matters whether you wear glasses or not.
I mean,
the fact the glasses do focus our
attention towards that a forward gaze.
But that doesn't mean we can't be
aware when you felt the effect. Right?
Yeah, yeah. There's an effect.
That's what matters. Okay. Yeah.
Yeah. Oh my gosh. Lots of question.
I'm going to go over here first.
All right.
So I heard over the year it's sort of
to a competing notions of posture and,
and you touched on one very nicely,
which is this tensegrity idea that the
body is a dynamic system supported by the
last density and by structure.
And then a second one that talks about,
you know,
this kind of rootedness where your
stacks of blocks stacking your bones and
trying to make sure that you're,
you're well supported through
your skeleton or there's
actually contradictory,
or is there if there was some
underlying principle behind them? Both.
I don't,
I like to think that they're both work.
But if you could have a stack of blocks
that was floating in a 10 sea grill
apparatus,
wouldn't that be better than just
compression block upon block upon block?
So I think I to Ralph's idea was stacks
of blocks that you saw it in her logo.
And she also talked a lot about
Buckminster fuller and tensegrity.
So she had both things
happening when she taught us.
And I think she just had it both
ways and hadn't integrated them.
And I think that's still true.
And I know that there are times when I'm
a stack of blocks and I can't help it,
you know.
But if you,
if you just move more
towards the conception that
you're a 10 Segretti I think
already that makes a change
in how you embody this flush.
And maybe I'm being too poetic.
I think this is hard and I've
wrestled with it myself. So yeah,
so both and is what I'd say.
But go towards the 10 Segretti
side as much as you can. And you,
did you understand what I said about
the awareness of space being a way of
perceiving 10 seg? Really?
Does that make sense to you?
I can't see you very well. You're
nodding your heads. Okay, great. Thanks.
So you've made me feel a little
hostile towards my desk chair. Could
is just adding a cushion sufficient
if it's tipped back like that or,
or what else should I get?
Well I like those cushions.
It doesn't work for everybody,
but I've tried every kind of little
chair thing you could find cause I write
books, you know, and I
found that having that,
that cushion that moves a
little bit, uh, is beneficial.
There are chairs that move,
they're very expensive.
They are later on like a
spring and you can find them.
You know
what else you should do is
bring your headphones and jam
for five minutes once an hour.
I'm serious. Like, look, look
for a chair that's flat or, well,
the chair should be at a height.
If I can pantomime this,
that your hips are higher than your
knees and the more high the better.
So the more you perch rather than sit
the better because that invites your
pelvis to roll forward,
which gives you a lift through your
lumbar spine and on up through the rest of
you. You could email me, you know,
send me a picture of your
chair and I answer emails.
So if you're struggling and you've,
you say, should I buy this chair?
You know? Thanks. Yeah.
Uh, so it's just standing
all day at your desk.
A healthier than sitting at your
desk all day with no motion.
You're going to move more if standing,
I think,
hmm,
maybe not.
You know what I have at my kitchen sink,
which is the place where I stand the
most if I'm, and also I have a staff,
I have a platform for my
computer that's on a shelf.
So it's like a standing desk. And both
of those places I've put a pebble bath,
a doormat. Have you seen those
doormat? Made of pebbles.
So that allows your feed a
little sensory experience,
gives you a little movement there.
More and more things coming through
the internet of standing desks with
different kinds of wobble boards. And
there's one that looks like a skateboard.
So you're like going like this. I don't
know how it would be. You have to tell me
thanks.
Um, having, uh, stood extensively
as well as using miniatures, um,
uh,
the chair is keeping you from your
normal fidgeting effectively. Yeah.
And I think that's why standing work so
well because so many of us tend to shift
from one leg to another lean one way
and then the other and the chair largely
prevents that movement while
standing allows it just stand
otherwise, you know? Yeah. So fidget away.
Thank you.
That's really true about fidgeting,
um, about those last two
videos you showed. Yeah.
What I observed most distinctively
between them is the earlier video,
the developing world video with the
women carrying things on their head. Um,
besides the fact that they may have
been functioning more efficiently just
because they had to because
of the weights on their heads.
They were walking in, in what
you might call, you know,
Caribbean time. They there,
they were walking at the rate that
was comfortable for their body.
So their body resonated naturally.
The, the people in the urban video,
we're rushing but not jogging.
So they were accelerating
a normal walk beyond the,
the natural speed of a normal walk,
at which point the bodies, um,
resonant frequency
doesn't match it anymore.
We are embarrassed to jog
because people will get upset.
They will think that something is wrong.
Yet we feel the need to get somewhere
faster because we're on the clock.
That is what I, I feel like
his is what drives that though?
Some of the people clearly
had health problems.
Well sure.
But I showed the difference because
just so you see that, you know,
quality of experience,
your mirror neurons pickup on
the movement that you look at.
[inaudible] so first
about the first video,
I have a hunch that it
was slowed down slightly.
It was a little bit in slow motion,
so it wasn't quite accurate. Um,
and the other one,
if any of those people jog do,
they would be jogging on hard surfaces.
So there's no rebound,
no gift from the earth.
So it would be jarring to the
spine and the whole body, you know?
So I'm all for it,
for more of us running to do things,
but we've paved paradise,
you know?
So I don't know the answer,
but I'm suggesting that
you do collectively.
Yeah.
Thank you so much for those questions.
Great.